[Aplausos]
techo y rey trabajo bueno hay que
regresar y está pensando pero bueno
techo tierra y trabajo es lo que el papá
francisco nos está pidiendo el día de
hoy a partir de los encuentros que ha
tenido con los movimientos sociales
sobre todo en bolivia techo tierra y
trabajo o derechos sagrados lo dice y lo
repite es por eso que nosotros estamos
precisamente aquí para hablarles un
poquito de lo que es el colectivo de
chope que somos un grupo de jóvenes
católicos que nos dedicamos
especialmente a la construcción de
vivienda alternativa respetando las
cuestiones naturales la madre tierra
teniendo en cuenta que es un ser vivo
como la llama también el papá francisco
en los datos y nuestra hermana madre
tierra y es por eso que les queremos
presentar de forma concreta cómo podemos
romper los paradigmas ahorita que
existen alrededor de la vivienda sobre
todo aquí en la ciudad porque porque
indudablemente cuál es la la oferta que
tiene el mercado para ahorita
ofrecer vivienda
viviendas que tienen materiales que por
lo general van
golpeando no las cuestiones que más
climatológicas entonces nosotros
tratamos por medio del barro la tierra
la basura sobre todo las pacas de paja
que son sistemas muy viejos que son
sistemas que realmente no estamos
inventando nada nuevo y tenemos tan
ideas tan nuevas simplemente estamos
rompiendo este paradigma regresando a
las cuestiones indígenas sobre todo a
las cuestiones a las primeras formas en
que el hombre trató de habitar no
refugiarse el clima entonces lo hacemos
desde la enseñanza social de la iglesia
poniendo en claro la dignidad de las
personas para este trabajo entonces
ahorita estamos en las diferentes zonas
de la periferia hemos estado en el
kilómetro 33 con los con lograr a
maurice ahorita estamos con lomas de
poleo
esto nace de una inspiración religiosa
en unos ejercicios ignacianos en donde
jesús es muy claro y nos hablaba sobre
estas cuestiones de la responsabilidad
social la lucha de la justicia social
entonces
como les mencionaba en los elementos
básicos para la construcción son la paja
y el barro
quiero hacer esta pregunta verdad que la
analicemos un poco cuál es la realidad
que estamos viviendo la intensidad
juárez el último el último estudio que
sacó la coneval hace dos años nos está
hablando muy claro que de 2.500
municipios que existen en méxico somos
el número 9 con el número más alto de
personas en pobreza no sé si ustedes
sabían esto pero nosotros entonces lo
que nos hace que no nos podamos detener
la situación que se está viviendo de 100
pesos
es difícil dar de 100 pesos que se
generan en mexico 13 pesos los genera
ciudad juárez esto quiere decir que no
puede existir una ciudad antes
balanceada no con un número tan grande
de riqueza que produzca tanta riqueza
contra un número tan tan fuerte de
pobreza extrema entonces
como les comentaba tratamos de romper
este paradigma en el integrarnos con la
gente desde la parroquia de nuestra
señora de la paz llevamos a jóvenes que
están en un nivel un poco en un nivel
medio medio alto tratamos de hacer que
se hermanen con las personas que están
en estas estás en estos asentamientos en
esta situación para que de alguna forma
se arremanguen para que nos demos cuenta
de la mística que existe en el pobre no
en este pobre que que nosotros desde
nuestra espiritualidad creemos que es
está en presente dios no que ahora hoy
sobre todo ellos son los profetas de
estos tiempos los migrantes todas las
personas que están en estas situaciones
y los jóvenes logran hermanar y
pueden ir y por mediodía dieron de las
imágenes con el barro y con la basura
que nosotros utilizamos ellos están lo
pisan en el proceso ellos informan en la
casa de otra persona y esto nos ha
llevado mucho a contemplar la forma en
que estos jóvenes de manera humilde se
empiezan a hermanar les cambia la vida y
para esto les voy a hablar de algunos
ejemplos muy claros nos tocó construir
por una comunidad en la colonia lópez
mateos por medio de un seminarista que
está en el grupo con nosotros fue a una
comunidad donde les habló de que
necesitaban y que qué era lo que
necesitaban ellos para poderse encontrar
con dios porque estaban en una casita
asignados y celebrando los ritos
religiosos no podrían
y en la celebración y esto nosotros
primos les presentamos les dijimos lo
que hacíamos y organizando la comunidad
pues este es el ejemplo claro de ahí se
ve un poquito las las imágenes de cómo
ellos mismos con sus manos las señoras y
las las viejitas que no dejaban de hacer
un rosario a las 7 de la noche y los
llevaban de comer ellas pisando el barro
haciendo los castillos todo lo que tiene
que ver con la construcción ellas bien
presentes
y esto fue lo que se logró ellos con ese
presente testimonio que nos dieron a
pesar de que les dieran la espalda ellos
creían en sí mismos y lograron hacer una
capilla para encontrarse con dios otro
de los ejemplos muy fuertes para
nosotros son estas dos personas no no es
luís que forma parte del colectivo que
para él tras su subida ha sido compleja
no ha sido sencilla
pudiera estar en otro lado para mí para
los que estamos allí lo podemos
contemplar que hace esfuerzos muy
grandes por estar allí y no se encontró
con esta otra persona cuando estábamos
construyendo la capilla
fernando ellis en el pelayo una persona
con adicciones a la heroína muy fuertes
nos criticaron porque le íbamos a
construir una vivienda a un drogadicto
no
ante todas estas situaciones no nos
detuvimos porque los invito a ver la
casa en donde vivíamos en donde vivían
perdón y llegamos al patio de la casa de
la mamá y eran unas cobijas hoy él vivía
entre cobijas cuando llovía y hay que
echar un plástico no ello viendo y pues
bueno no pudimos detenerlos a poder
ayudarlo no después de que le ayudamos
él dijo que le habíamos construido un
castillo y estaba muy contento después
de no ser dos semanas crípticos las
ventanas las quitó las metió para irse a
comprar heroína y aún así él sigue
estando bien con nosotros en cuanto
cuando cuando hemos ido a la colonia se
platica está con nosotros y sigue muy
agradecido en esa situación
otro de los ejemplos claros muy fuertes
que estamos viviendo ahorita sobre estas
dos personas es daniel alcalá y su hija
psoe ellos están orientan lomas de poleo
danielle sobre todo daniel vive en una
situación muy fuerte porque es
trabajador de la maquiladora quiere
estudiar no puede porque tiene que
llevar ahí dinero a la familia escucha o
sal no es un chavo bueno que nos da
testimonio todos los sábados que estamos
con él porque le está construyendo una
casa a su mamá que que tiene que tiene
problemas de cáncer y no ha podido sanar
por el hacinamiento en el que viven el
chau en frente de su casa
alrededor de la colonia lomas de poleo
si algún equipo no se sabe la situación
que se vive de drogadicción delincuencia
muy fuerte y aún así él sigue estando
fuera no y entonces para nosotros es muy
fuerte y admirable lo que hace al igual
que ángeles y su mamá
que los hemos visto cómo se quedan sin
comer por darnos a nosotros de comer y
siempre nos están dando lo que tienen
los escuchamos los contemplamos porque
nosotros encontramos ahí la mística de
lo que les hablaba desde el pobre no
encontrarnos ahí con dios
esta parte de la hermandad de formar
comunidad del que podamos de alguna
forma como jóvenes que tenemos y como
adultos también me han provenido estas
tenemos todo aquí ahorita en el público
está yo veo gente pudiente no que
tenemos todas las capacidades para
ponernos a imponernos a su servicio no
por ahí hacia una amigo hacia un
análisis de minutos incluso si sumáramos
dos minutos de acción social y
estaríamos logrando cambios muy
interesante en la ciudad si por esta
situación que les digo que no nos es muy
difícil caminar con ella
lo hacemos en entorno siempre a la
cuestión de la elaboración tratando
también de incluir a las personas de
alrededor para este
que podamos nosotros este hablar un poco
de esta situación
y quisiera terminar con esta
con esta reflexión es importante que
amemos con obras que no que no nos
detengamos a actuar sin fijarnos que
podemos llegar a hacer porque porque la
situación en juárez es muy compleja
entonces
es sencillo sino si nos proponemos
romper estos paradigmas
[Aplausos]